this action-packed episode is brought to
you by the bacon smokehouse burger it's
the newest flavor of the signature
crafted recipes by McDonald's hey and
welcome to honest trailer commentaries
the show weary watch and honest trailer
and expand on our 50 little jokes with
long drawn-out digressions that don't
necessarily go anywhere I'm here as
always with Joestar Dan Merle and
ant-man director Peyton Reed hello how
are you all doing here thank you so much
for joining us we in anticipation of
ant-man and lost which we are all highly
anticipating we thought we'd revisit
sand ant twice yeah the blimp well then
we are gonna revisit be honest trailer
for ant-man
feel free to call us out at any point if
we ever got anything wrong just say
pause tell us why we're idiots and and
though you are in a room full of ant-man
if not lovers then certainly passionate
defenders we got we had to crack some
jokes about it alright let's do it if
they're not honest you be the judge
Rousseau's spiritus no mercy so we would
expect that yeah alright let's go let's
go right in
[Music]
yep no I got it I'm sure no one's ever
asked you about yeah
anchor right actually did not end up
directing ant-man so so I'm gonna I'm
gonna call [ __ ] on that that's not
honest okay let's go well to finish the
line that it says it's from Edgar Wright
until he refused to get in line which I
believe is an exaggeration of what
occurred but just out of curiosity he
still he still has writer credit on the
movie or producer code or yeah he has a
co-writer credit with Joe Cornish yeah
and I believe executive producer credit
on the first movie yeah yeah so what if
nobody telling us what if Edgar Wright
remains in this film or what what if his
spirit liberal the film let's go we'll
go shop it basically you know Edgar Joe
wrote drafts and drafts for several
years of that movie and the general idea
of doing ant-man as a heist movie was
always Edgar and Jose which was a great
idea obviously as it went along I think
from the time they started I believe you
guys may know better than me that they
started writing that around the time
maybe they were developing Iron Man one
like really early on in the Marvel yeah
Incredible Hulk dark days yeah yeah MCU
yeah exactly so um you know I don't know
how much crosstalk there was at the time
at Marvel between what was going on
between Iron Man and ant-man
script wise but there are a lot of
parallels in in terms of you know Oh
which we're gonna get into and your
honest trailer by the way antagonist
with the same power set as the as a hero
that sort of stuff super scientist
industrialists all that sort of stuff so
I think part of the thing about you know
I can't
I don't really pretend to know what all
the creative differences between Edgar
and Marvel were other than really what
Edgar is said which is I wanted to make
a [ __ ] right movie they wanted to make
a Marvel movie but really by the time
you know he'd gone off and I think done
three other movies and the MCU had
really fundamentally changed in the
intervening time so he decided he could
not make the movie he wanted to make his
was just two hours of Nick Frost in a
pub yes talking about by talking about a
me
yes and and wit panning between the
drinks and so now the young so when I
came on Adam McKay and Rudd came on and
they were robbers are Dion obviously but
um they were reworking a script so we
all work together and McKay and I were
huge Marvel fans and they were there
were several elements that weren't in
any of those early drafts which is we
wanted to introduce you know the
Microverse from the comics the quantum
realm and we both missed Janet we like
the idea of Janet Van Dyne and kind of
doing this more generational thing and
there was really no mention of Janet at
all those early versions of the things
so he's already hang his mentor Scott
Lang as yeah okay exactly that was
always baked into Edgar Joseph drafts
and they've been a lot of talk to about
I think Joss Whedon had wanted ant-man
if not ant-man and wasp and Avengers and
kind of wasn't allowed to at the time
because they were hanging on to it for
the first day and man
so we like the idea of doing this thing
that was not only sort of you know a
generational thing with Hank and Scott
but also alluding to the loss of Janet
and really how that affected Hank and
hopes relationship that seemed really
strong to us um and then I'm trying to
what else you know that there were a
bunch of Scott's crew of the ex-cons was
a lot of guys like my memories like
there were maybe six or seven different
of like a full heist crew like full
highsec I have it's eating all the time
yeah yeah yeah yeah the Geico bat yeah
yeah there was a massive group of people
and we sort of ended up pairing that
down and really putting more of a focus
on Luis and building him up as a
character and giving you know I think it
was McKay who came up the idea of like
he was very paternalistic and served
waffles to the guys and then all the
baskin-robbins stuff and then the the
idea that there were I think was Bearer
and Ferrari who were writers who are
credited on him in the wasp who came in
and did uncredited work later on the
first damp man they sort of we came up
with the idea of these tip montages for
for Michael Payne yes good and those
guys sort of wrote those in in the first
movie and and and Rudd as well so deaths
or stuff came about sort of later
awesome all right well let's keep going
with the trailer so we're like one
second and you're right until he refused
to get in line comes a movie based on a
superhero so ridiculous you'll swear
Marvel's choosing the projects on a dare
that was always something too that was
baked in that you couldn't ignore an
ant-man like okay what's a man about
when he Street's down he's really small
he flies on around on an ant talks and
talks to answer you can control them
it's like well great what you could
control ants we just what do you tell
not to infest your house or something
like what's what's cool about that and
that was always a huge challenge of the
movie as sort of you know like the tone
is sort of baked in its inherently
absurd and that was something that we
continued to have a lot of fun way I'd
like to see the serious you know meet I
want to get a tweet from somebody saying
like how you man you screwed up I'm
financing my own ant-man and the wasp
we're gonna do this right we're gonna
we're gonna go gritty with this thing's
like yeah with our community of writers
yeah let's keep going and you've seen
Marvel movies based on Green giant's
Norse gods and these weirdos now get
ready for a hero so silly no one can
even keep a straight face when they say
his dumb name like you said the term
that just lead onto ends yeah yes they
are to change the name in this super
powered heist film that against all odds
actually kind of works I mean it's still
not letting someone join The Avengers
just because they're good with a bow and
arrow you'll notice a pause when shot
guys when we don't have sheep come on
that that's that's low-hanging fruit
Hawkeye Jen this is pre Ultron I think
now this was post Ultron Ultron came out
that ant-man came out so this was post
decision right there's no chance that
you know what happened was we were very
nice to Hawkeye with Ultron and so we I
think we thought we had to balance the
force a little bit I mean there was
probably a mantis give Hawkeye something
to do in age of Ultron
they did it you guys still took the pot
shot here's going here's the problem is
the
this is another backhanded compliment is
when the movies good it's hard to make
jokes about it so you deflect you go for
hot okay yeah you do the plot to other
movies and then you sucked up 30 seconds
of your eyes these are the things we
fall back on I got it sorry Jamie right
yep right meets God leg say yes wait
nope behind the candelabra haunted us as
we were shooting a movie and only if her
dress later because Hank damn tank baby
Scott we have Michael Douglas and one of
the first times on set when Michael
Douglas says all right Scott we've got
this quantum things Scott but Rudd and I
looked at each other's like holy [ __ ]
guys named Scott in the it was and and
it sort of haunted us this thing where
Rudd would always do the candelabra
version we say Scott in a course here we
do the weak candelabra came out was a
big wait nope not that one yeah that's
the guy a master thief who gets busted
every time he tries to get away with
anything it's true yeah it's busted
about three times his death will change
when he's not heartache Pibb a
billionaire industrialist who lost
control of his company to a bald former
ally you use bald as a pejorative there
well I was gonna say whether you are
doing more to further the stereotype of
bald men being evil yeah yeah yeah I
know I I had mixed feelings about that
it kept me up many nights I can't do
this it sound like a salary shot
actually weirdly we shot three weeks
with Darren cross in a Beatles wig and
then we had to go back and reshoot it so
I thought you do like a like a like a
Justice League thing where you just CGI
out the hairdo on his head for the same
reason I fought back against we have to
point out that he's bald and I think
it's only because
we have to then tie it into ant-man I'm
sorry yep yeah I get it yeah yep at
least he wasn't on a Segway yeah yes
it's true
it's Cape Cod who Padres in and plots to
uses advanced suit technology for evil
and if that sounds familiar it's because
it's the exact same premise as the first
Iron Man movie can you go back to the
shot of that yeah look at that I woke up
this morning and knowing I was gonna
come here and I looked in the mirror and
it's like well I've got this grey beard
I looked like like a sort of
malnourished version of Jeff Bridges in
this trailer and that's not gonna go
over well
um there there are obvious parallels
between the plot of Iron Man 1 and Ant
Man 1 and I think it's something that
was baked into edgar joe's draft from
the beginning by the time i came on it
was so fundamentally a part of the movie
that you couldn't really change it
mm-hmm and which at times was very
frustrating because it was a real
self-awareness of like well this is you
guys have done this before so I was
trying to do anything that we could do
at that point in kind of like Hey look
over here this is this is different that
was that was to me the single trickiest
thing about ant-man one that you have so
definitely pointed out okay yeah like
like you're saying development timelines
like this had been said they were being
written around the same time yo before
there wasn't him see you yeah exactly
there are little touches you put in that
I really love like Michael Douglas being
like this isn't just guns on a suit this
is real science yeah yeah but if you
yeah it's a much more boring movie if
they he develops the shrinking
technology to like help Amazon ship you
know it's faster you gotta build a tiny
suit otherwise it's how are you gonna
fight it I'd like to see that movie
actually that's the mundane the
logistics a shipping company version of
Batman yes not my favorite let's keep
watching
if it ain't broke I mean seriously
it even has that friend staring at the
suit though we're in the sequel moment
next time
not poss not for you worked out better
for Evangeline Lilly and her look at the
suit then I guess it did from Terrence
Howard that's all I'll say about that
did she ever come up and say like please
don't don't Terrence Howard me I I got
to look at it and they said I was gonna
wear it and I want to wear it I actually
said that to her just a thrill at
amazing visual effects that makes
seventy-year-old Michael Douglas look
like 60-year old my best jokin in the
other thank you killed me this was I
think I said before like this is the
most terrifying effect in a movie filled
with visual effects the sort of Youssef
ocation thing yeah because you were the
first one to do it right cuz they've
done it yeah or they did you know they
wrote one well no that was like
rebuilding reboot yeah yeah like if I
MCU Guardian yeah and this in an MCU and
with this methodology we were the first
one to do it and it's the weirdest thing
because we didn't like choose to do it
on some unknown actress Michael Douglas
everybody knows what he looked like 30
years ago and it's affect and effect
that like when you're in visual effect
review and you're watching the shot as
it progresses it's the worst most
horrible horrifying thing until it gets
to where it go right now because it
really just has this uncanny valley
thing and it's weird and it's it's a
very sophisticated thing and we do more
of it in the new movie and it's equally
terrifying I think that was the last
visual effect that came in on them Wow
because they take so long and it was you
know one of the first it was in the
first scene of the movie and it
terrified me because I give the
audience's like when they get go like oh
yeah he read the first shot of the movie
it's not really good for you you have
someone on the side just like brodo
scoping him out of Wall Street just as a
backup
yeah that's a tricky one okay keep going
and has harmless locations pulse with
epic danger like a briefcase a toy train
sentences were saying Michael Pena's job
in some possibly rut had Rudd felt there
was a crucial shot missing in this scene
which obviously we never shot but it
really he's like come on man let's push
it let's actually see what it would look
like from a man's perspective as as
Michael Payne he gets undressed and we
were voted down on that but that
discussion but I said but in 3d that
would have been amazing I'm a 3d you
just wish Kevin flag could we give you
guys more creative man yeah we could've
got we were really straitjacketed on
that alright keep going in some of the
most high-stakes fights between tiny
people
since Frodo versus Gollum proving your
arm I'll take that hasn't run out of
ways for guys to punch each other in the
face or in this movie's case sucker
count six sucker punches live in your
face alright pause I did not realize
until this honest trailer that we had
that many suckers
I really did I knew we had a couple of
two or three and it's so hyper violent
and great I stand by every one of those
sucker punches and in fact wish that
we'd had a couple more it's an effective
comedy straight yeah and I'm trying to
think if we have any sucker punches in
it man in the wasa I think you got to
see it Dan everyone wasp sucker I
remember Michael Pina gets it gets a
good punch in but I don't remember if it
is a sucker punch yeah but yeah yeah I
really hope that's how Avengers for
wraps up the script that is what
happened okay cool yeah
by the way everyone's gonna run with
that now yeah I can see that in vulture
tomorrow okay
that's how you punch
prepare for a movie that would be really
stale without Paul Rudd doing Paul Rudd
things because most reddit is hank pym
yammering on about some boring science
grad ha ha
pause that's true yeah he in the first
movie is a walking exposition machine
and one of the things that I promised
Michael the second movie is we're gonna
give you you've seen it slightly less
pseudoscience to talk about and another
problems I made we're gonna actually
give you a couple of jokes in this movie
and and actually some some real action
like if it's crucial to the plot well
they call out the science talking yeah
yeah yeah and that's that's always the
sort of the Rudd thing is you know is
being a step behind in terms of the
science and and hopefully echoing how
the audience is feeling about it but
someone's got to do it cuz every Marvel
movie like it's not just you know
there's Norse gods it's like well what
you called magic is actually science
over here with me and look at this
chalkboard I mean but if you're gonna do
it
to hear it come out of Michael Michael
Douglas's mouth yeah yeah it's the way
to do the best way all right keep going
to magnetic waves to stimulate their
olfactory nerve center must retrieve
this prototype of a signal decoy I
created a formula that altered atomic
relative distance yeah not freaky danger
you ain't said the topic was emotional
position have yet a different flavor
there's a nice little tone that delivery
alright fella want foul ball on us yeah
you've gone from the other 11 MCU movies
with a few unique twists like making
another schlubby comedian get abs for a
superhero roles boss actually kitty Paul
they just refer to your schlubby you
know where to find these guys that's
that's your I can't you you should
handle no clueless Paul Rudd I mean look
she's always been hot like he's not
really Paul Rudd and thing rekt we're
gonna slubby Asst he's been in a movie
man 2 yeah yeah it's good looking man
we're we're desperate yeah Wow look at
that reaching for parallels not always
actually getting you to care about
disgusting insect monsters no boss
disgusting insect monsters like this is
anything this was a one of the things we
want to do in the movie was see if we
could actually get some weird genuine
emotion out of killing an ant
a thing that we do almost daily in our
real life yeah yes and I think that we
we succeeded and we sort of riff on it
in the new movie in a way that it's a we
retreated a little more callously in the
second movie I now hesitate slightly
before I kill an ant yeah but we named a
spider in our apartment that's on you
nice keep coming
I like that one because he had a name ad
saying the one thing everyone's been
yelling at the screen since phase 2
started I think our first move should be
calling the Avengers so let's wrap it
over the best micro movie since Honey I
Shrunk the Kids
as Marvel possibly we actually one point
attempted to get a Rick Moranis cameo in
the first that was my next question
still during the period I think where he
wasn't doing so much acting I think he's
now gonna be on the a CTV Scorsese
directed thing which I'm super psyched
about them but always still an unchecked
box for me
part three yeah ant-man again Rick
Moranis Scott Lang's dad honey I blew up
the ant yeah okay yeah like that all
right thank you come I Shrunk the Kids
as Marvel proves once again they can
literally sell you anything and they
don't even have to try that hard so this
is really the only thing I care about is
yeah how did this happen yep what is
this okay
let's dissect this yes by far
everybody's favorite of all the sort of
30-second spots that were created for a
man this is my favorite because it's
just nuts and if I can figure out a way
to actually put it in the movie I would
have it in the movie and I think it they
we were on some generic sort of stage
where it's like we're just do some
promos you know Paul we know you love to
ad-lib and and kind of we don't have
anything written oh no no no we thought
you were just sort of ad-lib and I think
it was Paul sort of like let's just do
an ant song and they started doing ants
and then Michael jumped in and and that
became this 30 seconds of I showed up
everywhere and it's Anson
you know people signed poster and it's
ants ants and I think my memory of it is
just there was literally no script and
Paul's like I'll just start singing or
playing hambone yeah everyone that's
that's a beautiful thing that yes just
go riff and yeah man Wow okay yeah well
there you go there's things you're had
to try that hard to show it beautiful
vibe buzz where it's just like they just
had barely enough footage to cut that
30-second spot a couple shots and you're
coming in but it's insane I hope it won
a Clio or something yes
I love you Matt Tony Stark senior sure
wasp machine
yeah the only Latino in the MCU still
technically true I don't know time it
was it was sweet we did our research at
that time that was true and I'm I just
loved we just revered sue the other 11
movies and see you in this trailer like
wow man that escalated quickly yeah yeah
we're the 20th movie 20th now really
funny yeah easy it is crazy it's a long
run TV TV series right Thank You G in
this we gonna get abs say ti as himself
it's the biggest adventure they could
get please pause to pick your wager
uh yeah that was McKay I think we were
talking about the idea that in the
structure of a heist movie there's
always that sort of pre heist
trial-by-fire thing
and the comic-book fans we in us wanted
to see this fight and Falco just seemed
like the right level of hero that was it
could come into the movie mm-hmm we
liked the sort of the idea of matching
up those power sets for a fight and also
not big enough a hero that he was gonna
walk away with the movie in a weird way
so that's how that came about
it works its natural to the plot because
he is the one that they would just leave
back at home two guys just hanging out
role do we shoot the shot of what what
Sam was doing miss along with should was
he just watching ESPN boxing videos yeah
Thomas and the magic railroad commands
disposable Marvel villain number nine
pause go back look at that suit that's a
straight suit disposable and number nine
who or the other who are the other we
I'm trying to think up to that point it
was the low key and friends yeah yeah it
was I think Red Skull was probably in
there although that's like I think it
was the more the one-off villain in the
sense that like yeah there's a villain
who's in one movie and only one movie
conversation where you're like hey at
some point we're gonna run out of bad
guys and can we not keep killing them
well I mean you guys are making a
massive assumption there's an assumption
here that I'm not quite comfortable with
if you watch his death in the first
ant-man the suit is compromised he
shrinks and goes into a thing I mean we
could have gotten some Atomics somewhere
and let me somewhere still be alive down
there Wow
okay there you go is throwing that out
there thank you for keeping our industry
going for another week absolutely tiny
Iron Man yeah yeah - a tired man
not sure after this one I cannot imagine
these movies getting any strange oh yeah
I forgot about that I think this movie
weirder than Doctor Strange yep industry
yeah yeah it's more like bizarre as far
as the rest of the MCU I like that yeah
yeah we the quantum realm thing that we
added that was one of the things
that it felt like now we're doing so
much shrinking and let's take it further
in the third act and it was something
that Mackay was really hyped about and I
was really hyped about so we had no idea
was really we had hoped but we had no
idea if we were gonna be able to do
another movie we just wanted to actually
do that movie that's how you got to do
it but then when we did you know it made
a lot of sense to sort of expand on that
and as you've seen hopefully as you will
see yes we're gonna see what the fans
yeah what the real fans feel people Joe
lunch-pail yeah guys are gonna remake
ant-man real people well mystery thank
you so much for being a good sport about
this I know we want you to stick around
we'll bring some more sweet drops of
content out of you but but thank you for
going through this and we really
appreciate it and we all we all loved
the first movie so thanks for and I love
it I love what you guys are doing over
the honest trial of it they make me
laugh
we'll save you some time for the movies
that you guys do bring it on next look
out yeah we'll see you next week good
honest trailer commentaries by today's
episode brought to you by the signature
craft recipes by McDonald's
[Music]
you